Hey there, everyone.
I'm Joanna. And I'm Makita.
We are thrilled to invite all the professionals out there in Cebu
to a very special event happening this weekend.
That's right. It is our Canadian Immigration Seminar
and it's absolutely free to attend.
We know how daunting the process of immigrating to Canada can seem,
especially when you're considering bringing your family along.
But fear not, we've got you covered this weekend.
We prepared a comprehensive and interactive seminar just for you.
Whether you're a skilled worker,
a business professional
or someone with dreams of a better life in Canada,
this seminar is for you. We'll be sharing valuable insights,
tips and strategies
and how you can successfully bring your family to Canada this year.
Plus, we'll be answering all your burning questions
and providing personalized advice
to help you navigate the immigration process with ease.
Some market calendars for this Saturday at Fairfield by Marriott,
Montgomery City, Cebu.
Be there before two PM space is limited,
so be sure to reserve your spot now.
Join us for an event that could change your life.
Don't miss out on this incredible opportunity
to take the first step towards your Canadian dream.
See you at the Canadian Immigration Seminar.